today's video is brought to you by athletic greens
and it's a wonderful daily blend of vitamins
and minerals ag-1 by athletic greens is
a comprehensive all-in-one greens powder
engineered to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet and support your body's nutritional needs
across four pillars of health gut health immune
support energy and recovery it's packed with
75 vitamins and minerals and whole
foods sourced ingredients combining
the perfect amount of micronutrients
absorption and taste to jump start your
daily routine you'd be hard-pressed to find
a more comprehensive powder or supplement
on the market right now now as you guys know i'm
not exactly a fitness youtuber but i do like to
eat right and take care of myself and ag-1 is
that comprehensive nutrition supplement that
i know is going to account for any holes that i
might have in my diet take one scoop out of the
tin where i keep my ag-1 pop it in this water
bottle shake it up and i typically have this
in the morning with my coffee it tastes good
it's kind of sweet but it doesn't really contain
i think it's got less than one gram of sugar per
serving but it still tastes great plus by drinking
this i know it's filling all those gaps in my diet
which is nice plus ag-1 is gluten-free dairy-free
paleo-vegan keto low-allergen and low-calorie
yes less than 1 gram of sugar per serving 81 is
the perfect dietary supplement regimen so if this
sounds like the supplement you've been looking for
then you can grab your own immunity bundle which
gives you five of these free travel packs and a
year's supply of vitamin d as a bonus with your
first purchase athleticgreens.com forward slash
biographics again year supply vitamin d five
free travel packs athletic greens.com forward
slash biographics or just click the link in
the description below and now today's video
king henry v too famous to live
long england never lost a king
of so much worse those are the immortal
words of william shakespeare used to describe
our subject in today's video king henry v had a
short life and an even shorter reign so why is he
remembered as one of england's greatest monarchs
three simple words battle of agincourt widely
considered one of england's greatest victories
against its perennial enemy france it turned the
tide in the hundred years war and poised henry to
become the dual monarch of both nations whether
or not this actually happens well let's find out
as we explore the life and the reign of henry v
henry was born at monmouth castle in the welsh
town of the same name hence why he's also commonly
known as henry of monmouth strangely enough
nobody's really sure when he was born although we
know that he eventually became king he was not in
the line of succession at first so nobody bothered
to record his birth in the official records the
two most frequently used dates are september 16th
1386 and august 9 1387. henry was the eldest
of six children to henry bollingbrook and mary
debohan his mother died in 1394 after giving
birth to her final child while his father took
the throne of england by force from his cousin
richard ii and became king henry iv in 1399. once
his father ascended to the throne he named henry
of monmouth isaiah and granted him several titles
such as prince of wales and duke of lancaster
although he did not expect it henry embraced
his new role considering it his destiny to one
day rule over england and conquer france he was
enthusiastic when it came to learning all aspects
of government but he was absolutely enthralled
when it came to military matters that being said
he was still a young man one with absolute wealth
power and privilege and he'd like to use them to
his advantage when it came to letting his hair
down several medieval sources described henry
as being somewhat of a party boy in his youth
or an assidious cultivator of lasciviousness
to use contemporary parlance however it seems
that he got over his wild teenage phase pretty
fast by the time he ascended to the throne he
was better known for his piety than his partying
from a young age it became clear that henry was
a skilled warrior and commander his father king
henry iv not only encouraged his son's interest
in all things military but practically demanded
it he knew that all the books and training in
the world were no substitute for the real thing so
he thrust his son into the heat of battle from an
early age this was partially done out of necessity
since king henry iv had to contend with several
rebellions during his reign and he needed all the
good commanders that he could get his hands on
prince henry of monmouth distinguished himself
at the battle of shrewsbury in 1403 when he was
only 16 years old against his former guardian and
teacher sir henry hotspur percy although hotspur
originally been an ally of henry iv and helped him
seize power from richard ii he eventually rebelled
and managed to amass a large army of people who
wanted the king gone from the throne the battle
turned into a decisive victory for king henry iv
after hotspur was killed in battle but the king
almost lost his heir when prince henry of monmouth
was injured in battle and this wasn't any paper
cut either the 16 year old henry nearly died after
being shot in the head with a freaking arrow when
he was brought to the hospital henry still had
the arrow embedded deep in his skull but he made
a miraculous recovery thanks to the royal surgeon
john bradmore and as a unique treat bradmore not
only managed to save the prince's life but also
wrote a treatise detailing his treatment which
still survives to this day here is how the surgeon
described the ordeal the sun in air was struck by
an arrow next to his nose on the left side during
the battle of shrewsbury the arrow entered at an
angle and the head of the aforesaid arrow remained
in the furthermost part of the bone of the skull
for the depth of six inches first i made small
probes from the pith of an elder well dried and
well stitched in putrefied linen the length of the
wound these probes were infused with rose honey
and after that i made larger and longer probes so
that i continued to always enlarge these probes
until i had the width and depth of the wound as i
wished and after i prepared a new some tongs small
and hollow and with these the width of an arrow i
put these tongs in at an angle in the same way as
the arrow had first entered then placed the screw
in the center and finally the tongs entered the
socket of the arrowhead then by moving it to and
fro little by little i extracted the arrowhead
and then i cleansed the wound with a syringe
full of white wine and placed in new probes made
of wads of flax soaked in a cleansing ointment
and from the second day i shortened the said
wads every two days and thus within 20 days the
wound was perfectly well cleansed and afterwards
i regenerated the flesh with a dark ointment and
note that i always anointed him on the neck every
day in the morning and evening with anointment to
soothe the muscles and placed a hot plaster on top
on account of fear of spasm which was my greatest
fear and thus thanks to god it was perfectly cured
as you might imagine taking an arrow to the
face in the middle of a battle and living
to talk about it earned henry some serious
bragging rights with his soldiers this was
his first fight and already the prince developed
a reputation as a mighty warrior even with the
dorky bowl haircut that he tended to sport and it
didn't take long before prince henry was back in
the saddle both figuratively and literally ready
to take part in his next conflict this one wasn't
so easily solved though in 1400 the welsh leader
owen glinder instigated to revolt with the goal
of ending english rule in wales he turned into
a formidable foe who kept king henry iv busy for
years to come and in a way even bested him as he
sapped all the energy from the english king who
felt his body begin to fail him even though he was
still in his late 30s as a result of this henry
of monmouth started taking a more active role
in his father's government aided by his uncles
with free reign the prince decided to switch
tactics when it came to dealing with glinder
instead of the traditional raids and skirmishes he
adopted a war of attrition by setting up garrisons
in strategic locations to cut off his enemy's
supply routes this forced the welsh leader to
retreat into his main strongholds which henry
then attacked with siege weapons meanwhile he
also offered pardons to glinder's allies many of
which took them when they saw the tide turning
against them in 1409 glinder lost his last bastion
of safety harlech castle and was forced to retreat
into the mountains from there he conducted the
occasional raid but he wasn't a serious threat
anymore owen glinder disappeared completely from
the historical record in 1412 and his ultimate
fate remains a mystery it's said that only his
direct descendants know the location of his
final resting place and they're not in a sharing
mood as far as henry of monmouth was concerned he
impressed a lot of people with his military and
ministerial skills despite his young age by 1410
the prince had become the de facto ruler of the
country as the commander of the royal council but
he soon found himself at odds with his father the
two of them disagreed over policies specifically
when it came to france and although the prince
had his supporters his father was still the
king and his word was final fed up with his
son's eager and religious nature king henry iv
dismissed him from the council entirely in 1411.
however he did not take any more drastic steps
such as naming a new air this meant that for
the prince it simply became a waiting game
one that didn't take very long on march 20th 1413
henry iv's unknown affliction finally claimed
his life after years of poor health the following
months henry v was crowned the new king of england
now that henry was the man in charge he adopted
a conciliatory approach let bygones be bygones
he thought as he wanted to rule over a united
nation and also move away from his father's
legacy as many regarded him as a bit of a tyrant
henry restored titles and properties to many
noblemen who had been dispossessed by his father
chief among them edmund mortimer who had been
imprisoned for allying himself with henry hotspur
percy mortimer had been heir presumptive to king
richard ii so he would have ruled england if
henry iv had not taken power by force even now
he still had the second strongest claim to the
throne after henry v so it was a big gamble on
behalf of the new king to release edmund mortimer
from prison let alone restore his old authority
fortunately for henry the gamble paid off mortimer
knew not to bite the hand that fend him instead
of fighting again over the top position and
possibly dying or ending up in prison once
more mortimer's okay with playing second fiddle
and became one of henry's most trusted counselors
he remained loyal even after the king's death
and served part of the regency council to henry's
infant's son who became the new king of course
not everyone was a fan of henry v as is often
the case when a new ruler takes power especially
one so young there are people who see it as an
opportunity to sow the seeds of chaos thinking
that the unestablished inexperienced king will be
a bit of a pushover there are two such instances
during henry's reign that we should cover before
getting to his shenanigans in france first
there were the lollards a recent religious
movement initiated by theologian john wycliffe
a few decades earlier up until henry's reign
they were mostly tolerated but he felt they
were starting to gain too much traction so he
wanted to stop their momentum by arresting some of
their more prominent members instead the lollards
decided to fight back and an uprising took place
in 1414 led by one of henry's closest friends sir
john old castle previously the king had even
stayed old castle's execution when he had been
sentenced to death for heresy but for the night
his beliefs trumped his friendship with the king
yet a few hundred conspirators tried to sneak
into henry's palace in disguise but their poorly
planned plot had already been uncovered by the
king's spies and they proved no match for the
troops waiting for them old carson himself managed
to escape while his co-conspirators were all
hanged or burned at the stake but his freedom
was only temporary three years later old castle
was captured and executed by being burned
alive over a slow fire lovely the other
conspiracy against henry v took place in 1414
and was known as the southampton plot or the
cambridge plot named after its main instigator
richard of coinsborough third earl of cambridge
he alongside lord scrope and sir thomas gray were
noblemen still loyal to the former king richard
ii who believed that his heir the aforementioned
edmond mortimer was the rightful king of england
their plan was to assassinate henry thus paving
the way for mortimer to claim the throne they
didn't get a chance to establish how they were
actually going to do this because their little
intrigue was soon exposed to the king by none
other than edmund morton himself as we said the
former heir had consigned himself to the role of
sidekick as soon as he was informed of the plot he
was like i want nothing to do with this you people
are going to get me killed so he went straight to
the king and told him everything swearing that he
had nothing to do with it fortunately for him the
king believed him as far as the other three were
concerned though despite calls for clemency it was
off with their heads now the matters in england
had been settled henry v was finally able to do
what he'd always been wanting to do ever since he
was still a counselor for his father invade france
henry's war against france was part of the
larger conflict between the two nations known
as the hundred years war which despite
his name actually went on for 116 years
it also wasn't one continuous fight but
rather a series of wars separated by truces
when henry invaded france in 1415 there had been
peace between the two sides for over 25 years ever
since the time of his grandfather john of gaunt
who also spent most of his adult life fighting
the french the whole affair kicked off thanks
to henry's great-grandfather king edward iii
of england who said in 1340 that he had the
rightful claim to the french throne this was
the kind of complicated and incestuous web
of bloodlines that the european royals were
really good at weaving but the gist of it was that
edward iii had been the closest male relative to
the deceased french king but he was related
through his maternal line the french however
wanted someone related through a male bloodline
so instead they chose philip vi as their new king
of france ever since then the english kings who
followed edward iii gave themselves the unofficial
title of king of france just to signify that they
had not abandoned their claim and that the guy
who actually ruled france was just keeping the
throne warm for them when henry v took power he
decided that he didn't want his title to be merely
honorific so once matters were settled in england
he gathered his army and crossed the channel
in 1415. his first target was the port town
of harfleur it was a small but important
settlement so it was heavily fortified and
was able to withstand the english siege for
over a month before its inevitable surrender
on september 22 despite being a military loss the
siege of har floor was a boon for the french the
starters gave the french king charles the sixth
time to muster his troops but it also allowed a
deadly wave of dysentery to spread and wreak havoc
through the english ranks casualty estimates are
all over the map but they could have totaled a
maximum of 5 000 soldiers from both disease and
fighting considering that henry's initial army
was slightly over 11 000 troops that meant that
he probably lost at least a third up to almost
half of his army just besieging this little
town all of a sudden henry's dream of conquering
france seemed dead in the water but then something
happened that bestowed henry the reputation
as one of the greatest military commanders
in english history with his army decimated
the king was forced to abandon his plan of
attacking paris instead henry wanted to march
to calais and retreat to england to regroup the
french of course had no intention of letting
him leave quietly they saw their opportunity
to crush their foe and they were absolutely going
to take it they met the english army at agincourt
there is no definitive source on the size of
the french army some claim twelve thousand
others all the way up to thirty thousand
suffice to say that it was significantly
larger than what henry was working with so the
french military leaders regarded this fight
as a mere bagatelle on october 25 1415 henry
proved them very very wrong let's start with
the battlefield although we're not sure of the
exact location of the battle witness account
said that henry lured the french army into the
narrowest section of the field wedged between
two wooded areas in order to make it hard for them
to maneuver movement was also heavily impeded by
thick and slippery mud caused by heavy rains there
knowing that the french had a strong cavalry henry
erected a row of sharp stakes in front of his
soldiers to stop the enemy's charge finally he
employed his secret weapon the longbow in past
battles the english longbow had proven to be
devastatingly effective so the french knights had
no choice but to wear heavy armor that was thick
enough to stop the arrows from piercing through
the battle that was supposed to be a gimme for the
french soon turned into an absolute bloodbath the
rank and file soldiers were swiftly decimated by
the neverending hail of arrows whereas the heavily
armored men at arms were exhausted from moving
through the muddy terrain and those who fell
down found it almost impossible to get up again
indeed a large part of the french army had not
been killed by sharp english steel but by being
suffocated in the mud or getting trampled by
friendly forces when it was all said and done
henry stood triumphant next to a giant pile
of corpses that numbered up to 6 000 frenchmen
whereas he only lost a few hundred soldiers
himself it was an overwhelming victory
any way that you looked did it henry still didn't
have an army big enough to take full advantage of
it instead he returned to england where he was
greeted as a hero and began making preparations
for a new invasion in early 1417 henry was ready
to travel to france again this time there were
no hair-raising skin-of-the-teeth moments instead
the king preferred a systematic series of sieges
of strategically important cities on his way to
paris it took a lot longer and was nowhere near
as exciting but it was effective nonetheless by
1419 henry had taken cannes normandy and rule and
paris seemed like an inevitability he was aided by
the fact that the french were dealing with their
own internal strifes and struggles for power just
because they had a common enemy did not mean that
all the various french fractions played nice with
each other quite the opposite in fact the duke
of burgundy one of the most powerful men in the
country favored a diplomatic treaty with henry
because of this he was assassinated in 1419 by
his enemies and his son philip the good allied
himself with england and helped negotiate a treaty
between henry and charles vi the king of france
on may 21 1420 england and france signed the
treaty of troy's charles the sixth disinherited
his eldest son the default charles vii and
married his daughter catherine of valois to
henry who became the new regent of france and had
his bloodline recognized as a rightful successor
to the french throne in other words charles was
allowed to remain king while he lived but once
he bit the dust the crown owed to henry or his
sons on paper henry had accomplished his goals
however he knew that actually getting the treaty
enforced was another matter because there was an
ongoing power struggle in france some factions
had allied themselves with the dothran and some
kept fighting the english hoping to reinstate
charles the seventh of the year they even brought
in the scottish on their side since they
were always down to kill a few englishmen
this left henry no choice but to return
to france in 1429 for his third military
campaign this one however would prove to be his
last at first things went well henry once again
adopted the safest strategy of prolonged
sieges until his opponent surrendered but
just like at half-life dysentery swept through the
english camp and the king himself fell prey to its
noxious clutches ultimately it wasn't the arrows
or swords of his enemies that befell king henry v
but a lethal illness which took his life suddenly
on august 31 1422 henry was only 35 years old at
the time of his death and he was quickly followed
by the french king who died two months later this
meant that his infant son henry vi became the new
king of england and france but as you might expect
a lot of people weren't too keen on the idea so
the hundred years war resumed once more so i hope
you enjoyed today's video quick plug here at the
end if you enjoyed today's biographics which has
a lot of war content in it then i imagine you're
going to like my new channel wara graphics where
we do this sort of thing but it's all about wars
exclusively check it out there's a link below or
just search youtube for war or graphics
and you'll be fine see you next time you